I'm wondering uh what percentage of
filmmakers who approached you have no
sort of preparation done as far as like
social media presence they just have
this film that they think it's just this
great masterpiece and they've done no
prior work and building an audience well
what I find is that most of the time
when I start talking about social media
and start saying you know what have you
been doing online and what is your
transmedia strategy and what is your
audience engagement strategy and all
this I get huge groans of distress from
filmmakers and that most of the time
they've done very very little they know
they're supposed to but they really have
not found the time I know that John had
evangelized for a while about the idea
of bringing on people you call the
producer of marketing and directing as a
PMD more time distribution marketing
distribution so that you have people
doing that and that so the filmmaker
themself doesn't have to the one other
thing that I would add is that I have
gone to a lot of grad schools business
schools and people are aware that one of
the few growth areas in the economy is
social media marketing so there are a
lot of students out there who understand
that gaming social media marketing
skills is something that can prepare
them for the job world so if you can get
really good interns to do that for you
by all means we all know interns are a
double-edged sword they're often very
bad but in general I find filmmakers are
not prepared but not because they don't
want to be they just can't find the time
I find yeah I would say 80 to 90% of
filmmakers that I've encountered haven't
done it might be aware I still find some
that aren't aware that they should have
been doing it like that's more 20% you
know an 80% are aware that they should
be doing it but still only 20% of those
or
doing anything you know so and again
it's it's it's hard because it's it's
it's a double it's two things one is
time and the other thing is is that a
lot of times people who have a
filmmaking temperament aren't
necessarily suited to social media you
know and aren't kind of self promotional
in that way and that was those are the
two reasons why I think it's good to
bring someone else under keen to help
you with that
but again it's hard you know I do
realize that it's hard with smaller
budgets that you know then it's one more
mouth to feed you know but it's just the
way things are these days you know and I
just said I think social media is easier
to conceive of how to use properly for
documentaries than it is for narrative
features because documentaries tend to
have this whole world to build outside
and you know there's always gonna be a
ton of footage you're not using in your
documentary there's always gonna be many
ways to link to articles that are about
the same subject and that kind of thing
narrative features with their own
individual story it's a lot harder to
figure out how to engage your audience
yes and no though because I think this
is where the notion of what is still
mean it has to be called into question
and what is it like is it you know I've
started saying that you know just going
out and making a picture film it's like
washing your clothes in the brook you
know it's like it's a new world out
there and that you need to think about
social media as a media platform and
think of the creative ways that you can
engage your audience through alternate
various media channels which is then
basically turning narrative projects
into transmedia projects where it's not
just the film right but transmedia has
been tremendously successful for genre
films and some iconic films but it's a
lot harder for that independent artsy
kind of private independent
arty projects have a smaller audience
and are just tougher in general anyway I
mean it's just like you have to figure
out like how you're going to take that
film and connect it to a
audience whether that's a concern first
of all whether that's a concern of yours
which you know may or may not be the
case because there are those people I
just want to make my film and who cares
you know
in which case we'd go back to that
notion that well you better make it very
inexpensively or you better be rich and
but the other thing is is that I think
that you you just have to I think you
have to just think more creatively than
just the future filament yes transmedia
has been more successful in genre but I
don't think that that's you know
necessarily what the potential I think
there is greater potential you just have
to be as creative with thinking about
expanding the possibilities as you would
be with the individual film and in part
of it to me it's just an attitude and a
mindset like if you're just thinking oh
I just the future don't maker and this
is all that I'm doing you know well
that's I think that will limit you you
know but if you think I can do a
webseries I can do an iPhone app I can
do like I can engage I can have my
characters engaging people via social
media and you know you just have to
think you know broader and bigger in a
sense yeah I actually did a seminar
recently with about 20 filmmakers so we
just went around the room and said I
want each of the each had a film that it
was in some state of production or over
pre-production or some post-production
and I want each of you to now sit here
and tell me what your transmedia social
medias story would be for this film and
there was one person who was exceptional
at it you know she had everything from
fake characters who had their own social
media world and you know brands and all
kinds of products and all that kind of
stuff and then the probably the other 19
looked at me like I was crazy and I said
listen you just have to figure this out
I'm sorry it's difficult it is difficult
but you're gonna have to do this you
know to